you can see like even for such a small
set of ideas right you remember that
table we just drew it's not that
complicated but there's so many
different ways you can turn it right
here's a new function find where it's
increasing hence sketch its showing
stationary points will notice then it's
not asking for intercepts even though
you would usually assume that their
intercepts I wonder if you can work out
as we go through this why it's the case
that they're not going to ask foodstuffs
for a lot of these examples let's try
this
what's a standard post have been so far
I'm going to differentiate on time right
like I mean I could I could rewrite F if
I need to if it was in that form that
was all could you differentiate but this
guy's about as foods against rights I
don't need to do any continue I'm just
gonna go straight to head back sorry
this is question crazy okay - help me up
when we can just say this outside 6x
squared plus - sorry before just to
remember why is the four contribute
nothing to the derivative while it's
doing is shifting up and down like
shifting up and down not changing how it
behaves it's changing its position what
I do this what am I looking for
I want to know what it's increasing
I want to soul right so I'm going to
introduce when the function is
increasing right when the function is
increasing f of X is greater than zero
okay now just just notice this right
remember I said oh please please say
something please provide me like the
connecting pieces here right just
consider what it would mean to not have
written this just just think about what
it would look like if that line wasn't
there I've calculated the derivative
when I if I were to take out this line
okay what kind of argument I say I've
got it through video and then suddenly I
say the derivative is positive well no
it's not for a whole bunch of values an
infinite number of values I'm about to
show you what they are in a minute it's
not greater than zero right so it only
makes sense because I qualify it like
this do you see how important it is to
try and sure yes okay
I've computed my derivative so I'm going
to substitute in alright so I swear
thanks please take well it's increasing
substrate is zero okay I have a
quadratic inequality have a quadratic
inequality why don't I have a contract
in equality
well facade is why not when I
differentiate it I had a cubic square
I'll let you keep think about that you
still haven't given me a geometric
answer yet but you'll have one by the
time we finish this question keep
thinking about it if you've got a bit of
an answer let the rest of us catch up
with you okay what am I going to do this
to solve it I can divide by 6 because 6
is positive nothing happens to the
direction of the inequality or good can
I factorize this okay right someone give
you the factorization
okay so hopefully we can see this
clearly in our minds enough that you got
a root here negative one you've gotta
read it to X it was two I should say
negative 1 2 is a chrome came up with
concave down it's concave up okay I want
the positive bits that's to the left and
to the right the outsides right so I'm
going to say therefore X is less than 1
for X is greater than 2 it's or because
there's no value of x that can be both
of those and simultaneously okay so I
posted the first part of question yes
okay now I want to try and graph this
thing right what does this mean what
does this mean given that I know it's a
cubic okay I need one more pair of piece
of information to really do this
properly okay between here sorry I
should say to the left of here I'm
increasing to the right of here I'm also
increasing what does that imply if
that's the outside what does that imply
about the middle okay so broadly
speaking right this part is increasing
this part is also increasing but in the
20 it's going to be decreasing and
that's kind of what gimmicks do right
it's kind of what cubics do now do you
kind of see why of course you have to
have a quadratic
that's the inequality you're going to
get because you need to have XI regions
where it's increasing do you see that
cubic sigh like that by their very
nature
now in order to really nicely graph this
I kind of want to know this spot and
this spot because I gave you an overview
of the course I kind of already told you
what there's a cord right what are they
called
they've got two names because they stop
they're not going up not going down and
there we call them stationary points but
these stationary points
also they go they go up and then down
and then up right so they turn around
and then next minute right so I sort of
want to know where they are how do I
look that out hold on I've kind of
already solved that what you're asking
me because by solving this you see I
already have the boundaries right so I
know what this x value will be as well
yes right so I'm gonna need space over
here I'm gonna say F on negative one
that's gonna give me some coordinates
okay here's the function up here help me
out two times okay that's all thing yeah
so two times negative one because that's
what they gave one cubed is 3 times 1
minus 12 times 1 plus 4 UK with that I
think I did this one is it 11 yeah good
your other one just to save you time
because in principle this is not
difficult ok I think you'll get negative
16 you go and check it out you may have
already got that ok so now I know right
and negative 1 comma 11 it turns and
then a 2 comma negative 16 it turns
again I'm ready to draw
yes like yes yes they can um it is a
little bit but if the question is
crafted properly it won't be impossible
like you can't solve some Cubans some
cubics are very easy to solve like say
this one right I guess there's not that
hard and there is an expert
even even this is not that hard to solve
either right so this is not impossible
okay now what are we gonna do this thing
right
I have these points where turns I know
where it's increasing which kind of
implies I also know where it's
decreasing right so I'm ready to do this
thing
um what's up gone too far maybe one I'm
just going to kind of arbitrarily put a
lemon there all right
so that's negative one and eleven then
BAM that's one Spock my next point is at
two one two but if I want to keep that
roughly to scale bring that down and go
a little bit further maybe somewhere
like that and you can tell me that like
you're roughly the ballpark
okay all right now I know what's going
to happen how the graph is going to
behave on the outsides because it's
increasing so I've got to increase up to
that point right increase up to that
point I mentioned before I'm excluding
the roots from this you can't find what
the roots are but I will talk about that
in a second once I'm done with this okay
down here I know to the right of x
equals 2x magnitude it's also increasing
okay and then in between it does what
all cubic students and does that then my
scale is pretty bad because that's
supposed to be 4 but you just have to
give me for that okay because of course
you can see that on that intercept is
just sitting there okay but you get the
general idea right now let's make a
couple of comments on this before you
move on
I didn't ask for the intercepts then you
can solve where the intercepts are where
is this thing and this thing and this
thing okay however and I will leave it
to you it's not hard to experiment with
this I will leave it you to ignore the
fact that
did you notice my stationary points
right my points where I stop and turn
around my session was a very nice and
neat values like this that necessitates
the other points these guys being neat
as well right the difference the
connection between them is
differentiating if one is neat the other
will be messy by necessity okay and by
specify if I gave you something like X Y
is something simple like this what are
the roots of this these are nice easy
roots 0 negative 1 positive 1 okay
what I have a guy at this this is X if I
call that ass okay quickly differentiate
for me
okay now when I go ahead and solve this
for when they go stationary when it
turns around and so on okay you're going
to get messy values in it suddenly might
get whole numbers right I want to plus
or minus one over three I think you're
going to get something gross and in fact
that's about as nice as it gets
honestly if your roots if your
intercepts are nice the stationary
points will be crushed and the
stationary points are nice then the
intercepts will be worse okay all it's
not hard to experiment as to what